Hey! Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
In this video, we're going to show you some sensors,
that we've installed on the land.
Including this wind meter.
And, also we're going to talk more about all the electronics,
and how we hooked everything up together.
We're going to show you a map, because we're currently mapping out
all the native trees on the land!
To think about the future of our landscape.
So, get ready for some geeky stuff.
Hello, guys!
- Hello!
Who are you?
- I'm Naomi!
I'm Ceren!
I'm going to be here for two months,
and I'm from the Netherlands.
I'm going to be logging native trees in the area!
We're now up the rock, with Basekamp down there.
I think it would be great to show all the native trees in the area,
in contrast to all the mimosa and eucalyptus.
And, in the future, they might want to build stuff.
I recommend not to build next to native trees,
because you might need to chop them...
You want to regenerate the whole land.
I just picked a waypoint app,
so I'm going to be standing next to a tree...
Wait until the GPS locates me...
And then, I create a waypoint, add some information...
Like, the name, the height of the tree, and give it a color code.
And then, we'll walk to the next one.
- We have Ziggy here for support, right?
Mental support!
- Just eating the trees.
Yeah, we tried to teach him to eat
eucalyptus and the mimosa.
You just like sticks a lot?
- You think that will solve the problem
of Project Kamp with the mimosas?
We might need a lot of dogs...
- Just dogs!
All right, let's do it!
- Cool!
This is the app, and the blue spot shows where we are.
This green area is Basekamp.
Here, we have the old ruins.
We just walked up here.
I'll show you the logs I did now...
The walk to Basekamp is all mimosa forest.
And then, the first native tree I saw I spotted.
And just, like, logged everything I saw!
The different color codes, like the red ones,
are the strawberry trees.
Green ones are the oak trees.
English oak.
Pink is a cork tree, which we really love here.
And, the pine trees are the black ones.
It's fun to see that the whole line
is already like the border of our land.
But, this one, it's all like planted eucalyptus trees.
So, I just worked my way up till the big rock.
And this was my first area,
the app is called Tracklia.
Next to the Tracklia app, for the waypoints, I use Pl@ntnet,
and it is an identifying app.
You can download it for free, and put your location in.
And, so, we're in Europe now.
You can add photos from your gallery,
or even like take them new.
You add a picture like from a leaf!
You can add like it's a leaf or fruit, bark, or flower,
and it helps identify the specific species.
- What are strawberry trees?
Strawberry trees are bush-like trees.
We can back up in a bit.
It has different branches, and the little fruits
are like spiky strawberry like fruits.
And, I think the name is just like
because the fruit turns red.
It looks like a strawberry,
- But, you can't eat them, right?
I'm actually not sure.
- You can!
You can?
That's fun!
- They stick to your teeth.
Oh, we should try them, if they're better than strawberries!
- Are they tasty?
I haven't tried, and we'll definitely try now!
These are little fruits!
- I think I've seen them already!
They're turning already!
- They're turning red already.
They have to be soft.
- A strawberry tree!
And, that's amazing for a woodcarving,
if you want to make a spoon or something.
- Did you bite on it?
Yeah.
It doesn't even look like a strawberry.
- It doesn't, does it?
Sorry, if that's on camera.
Please don't put it in...
Ziggy, what tree is that?
Is that an oak?
Mimosa.
We try to teach him not to eat the oak...
Only mimosa.
What do we have there?
It's an oak?
- It’s an English oak.
And, you can see the light green, short stalks,
at the beginning of the stalk.
The most common one in the land here.
This is a cork tree.
This is the burned mother tree,
and it has new growth.
So, we will log this.
I will stand next to it as close as I can...
Get the GPS going again...
Make a waypoint...
Cork tree.
Oak, sorry.
And then, it's logged right there!
- Are there many cork trees left here?
Yeah, actually, I would say quite a lot, like a few big ones.
You can actually see the bark has been burnt.
Or, it has been burnt, but around it all new ones sprout.
I wouldn't say it is the most common tree here...
But, yeah, they could come back,
so I'm quite optimistic about these!
- All right! Let's go to the next one!
There is a pine.
- There's pine!
Quite a tall one, I would say.
And then, as close as I can, I will make a waypoint.
I chose the color black for this icon and saved it.
There you have it!
- Bueno!
What is this?
- This is a Pyrenees oak.
So, you can differentiate between the English oak,
and the Pyrenees by looking at the leaves.
This is quite velvety, almost like hairy,
especially on the back.
It feels very soft, and the color is a bit
more a grayish-green.
And, that is one of the characteristics of the Pyrenees oak.
We're here at the English oak.
These are called plant galls.
They're actually like abnormal growths in the oak.
They're caused by various parasites,
such as fungi, or bacteria, mites, or even wasps.
They're actually empty now.
They start out really green,
and they dry out with a very papery feeling.
They're quite common in oaks.
So, yeah, this is the terracotta pot I just found.
These can be found all up in the mimosa forest,
and, like, up the big rock.
They're all broken, but they used to be used
to have them for gathering all the resin from the mimosa.
So, if you cut the mimosa bark,
it slowly, like, pours out resin.
It's actually quite nice!
We find them, and we take them back to the Kamp.
We use them for like slow watering,
and put them next to plants and stuff.
So, we try to gather as much as we can.
- They are burnt, right?
They’re burnt, yeah...
- From the last fire.
Yeah, in 2018, if I remember?
- 2017.
2017?
- Yeah.
So, most of them are burnt, when we find them.
This is what you do?
- Yes! This is what I do all day!
Yeah, so, knowing that the path we just walked
is the border of the land.
Down there is the road.
So, I just need to get like zigzag
through every meter of the mimosa forest.
Knowing that the mimosa represses
other species growth...
We won't find any other species,
than just maybe some eucalyptus.
Sometimes, some thorns, like brambles.
But, just to be safe as a good ecologist,
you need to get like every meter.
So, I'll just continue zig-zagging my way through this area.
- All right!
That's it for today, huh?
- That's it for today!
We did a square today.
A square’s a hectare.
It wasn't really a dense area,
so we could get a lot done today.
Yeah, I would say that the whole project area
is around more than ten hectares.
I hope to get like all the logging
of the native trees done...
But, it will be a very hard project to do.
Some hectares are very packed in native trees.
The one we just did this afternoon,
or this morning wasn't really dense...
It was mostly mimosa forest.
So, yeah, it's going to be a lot of work, but a lot of fun.
Hey! I'm Jerry!
I'm from the Netherlands!
I've been here for a week,
to install a whole monitoring system.
So, the last season, Dave installed the solar panels,
and all of these electronics.
And, back then, he already mentioned that it's important
to be able to get some statistics out of this.
Because, here at Project Kamp,
we want to measure different aspects of off grid living
We want to see how the land grows, and how it evolves.
So, to make a uniform platform for this,
I installed a Raspberry Pi running Home Assistant.
And, that is really a big open source project,
which is made for home automation.
So, to capture a lot of data sensor input.
And based on that, also control different aspects.
So, with that, we know how much energy we use...
How much solar power we are generating...
And, how much is still left in the battery, for example.
Over time, we can add more sensors,
like a weather station, which we will show in a bit.
But, also, more sensors like a water well sensor,
to see if we still have enough water.
And, to keep all of this organized,
we made a display inside of the kitchen container.
Where we show if the battery is charging, how much AC power
we are using, and how much is still left in the battery.
So, for that, we mounted this display,
where you can see that currently the battery is at 63%.
And, it's in the green this arrow,
so that means that the battery is now charging.
That's because the solar is generating a lot of energy.
So, in the morning it was kind of cloudy,
but now the weather is getting better.
We're generating more electricity,
and we're basically not consuming any AC power,
Not a lot!
So, it's mainly just the fridge being on,
and some tools being used on the ruin.
The coolest thing here is that you see that there
is zero kilowatt hours from the grid!
Because, we are basically just fully off grid!
So, we really rely on solar energy,
and energy stored in the battery.
And, with this system, we can basically track
a lot of different sensors and different setups.
So, we also implemented a weather station,
where we can see how the ground temperature is evolving...
How much light is being shined
on different parts of the land...
And also, the soil.
So, if the soil is very dry or if it's very wet.
Lately, it's been very dry, because basically the last two weeks
have been super hot and with no rain at all.
And, over time, we also want to track
different, more manual settings.
Manual sensors, as you wish.
So, for example, the amount of people
at one time at Project Kamp...
The times that we've seen foxes...
The amount of gas bottles that we still use...
Because, this is the only fossil fuel,
that we are still relying on.
And also, the amount of water that we consume.
That goes through the system,
and goes back into the well.
Here, we have a small sensor setup.
So, it's being powered by a small solar panel,
and this generates all the electricity that the sensor needs.
And then, once every 15 minutes,
it sends it to the Raspberry Pi, that I showed in the back.
And, that really captures and logs all the data.
This is a small food container box.
We thought it would be useful to use, to keep it waterproof.
And, these are just very simple microcontrollers.
So, we really want to create a platform that different people
can create different sensors to measure different aspects of the land.
Okay, so, that's everything
about the weather station here.
Over time, there will be more sensors, more statistics...
But, this is a nice first introduction.
And, basically, from here on,
we will keep you up to date in the future.
For now, enjoy the rest of the video and see you.
So, one sensor we've installed, before Jerry came,
with all these geeky sensors is this wind meter.
It measures the strength of the wind.
The main reason for installing this was to check
if it's worth it to add a wind turbine to generate electricity.
So, we actually already installed it last year
on the top of the highest point of the land.
But, we realized whatever electricity we generate there,
we're probably not going to put a wind turbine there.
Because, we need to pull the cable
all the way to Basekamp.
So, since a few months, we put it here in Basekamp.
Because, it would be way more realistic,
if we get electricity to actually hook it up to our system.
And, it probably would be more of a small wind turbine...
There was more wind up the rock,
but, yeah, it's harder to get the electricity....
So, here, it would be a smaller turbine,
with probably bigger blades, but a small motor.
So, here you can see a simulation of what
a three meter blade would look like.
And overall, this project is some research done by From Waste to Wind.
They're actually with Precious Plastic trying to make a wind turbine,
from recycled plastic and using 3D printing.
You can find more about that research here.
But yeah, overall, it's an ongoing topic.
And ideally, also, we hooked this one up to our system,
that we have it digitally and synched.
So, it's easier to extract all the data.
This is still generation one.
Hello!
Today, we are in São Joaninho.
Daniel invited us on his property to pick oranges.
Because, he's working in the United Nations,
and he's not here to pick them.
They just rot away.
So, he sent us an email and invited us,
and we're going to pick some fresh oranges.
We have Charan!
We have Julie!
And, we have Ted!
And, me, of course, Felix.
So, you have it a lot in Portugal that people
have orange trees on their property.
And, since the young people move away, or I don't know,
go for work in the big cities and just not get picked.
So, in a lot of places, you have a lot of orange trees,
with a lot of falling oranges.
Fresh and nice to eat, but no one picks them.
Here, we have all the picked oranges.
Took us maybe 10 minutes,
Quite a lot!
There are still some left in the tree,
but I guess that's kind of everything we need for the moment!
So, thank you, Daniel, for the oranges!
Of course, we use oranges after plucking them.
We made some, some orange juice for breakfast,
and we made an orange cake.
You can make many more things with oranges,
and I think we're also going to look into preserving the oranges.
So, for instance, drying them by making a drying rack.
For drying the peels, and drying maybe all of the orange,
in order to preserve them.
To save as much oranges as we can from the trees,
that are producing them, but the consumers that are not there anymore.
All right, so, that was it for this video!
The next video is number 58!
So, we're going to talk about our current problems or challenges.
We also are going to do a Q&A.
So, if you guys have any questions for me,
the project, some people here...
Let us know in the comments,
and then we can talk about them next week.
All right, that was it for this video.
Thanks for watching!
If you really see the next update,
make sure to support the Patreon.
If not, no problem!
We'll just see you again next week,
on the same channel and the same time!
Bye!
Hey there, it's me again!
Felix, the video maker who made the videos,
in the last four months for this channel.
I guess you know it already...
I'm going to stop with my work.
If you want to know more about that,
there is a little message in the Project Kamp community section.
Anyway, I just wanted to say:
Thank you guys for your amazing support,
and the lovely comments in the last videos!
Really made me happy to read that!
And, if you want, you can have a look on my Instagram.
Or, my website, and stay tuned.
New people are going to come.
Also, a new video maker.
So, I guess it's going to be exciting!
I'm going to go back to Germany soon!
So, I hope you enjoyed the show,
and thank you again and take care!
Goodbye!